[Musik]
schwarz vermummt marschieren sie durch
Stuttgarts Straßen skandieren Rache
jeder Tat folgt die
Vergeltung eine Gewalteskalation die
sehr erschreckend ist war vielleicht
Schuss Nummer 19 das hat sicherlich eine
deutlich neue Dimension zwei
multiethnische Banden bekriegen sich im
Großraum Stuttgart mit schweren Waffen
Kriminalität als Lebensentwurf crime
Lifestyle Verbrechen verbindet Gangster
Rap als
Kid ich will wissen was treibt die
jungen Männer und wie reagiert die
Polizei Stuttgart Stammheim Anfang
Dezember ein junger Mann steht vor
Gericht er hat die bislang gefährlichste
Tat im Bandenkrieg verübt eine
Handgranate
geworfen die Polizei rückt mit einem
Großaufgebot an sie fürchten einen
Aufzug der Banden und Vergeltung denn
jede Tat der einen Gruppe wird von der
anderen brutal bestraft es herrscht die
höchste Sicherheitsstufe als Beamte den
23-Jährigen Iraner in den Saal führen er
ist 2016 mit seiner Familie nach
Deutschland geflüchtet die Tat gesteht
er schweigt aber dazu Ehrenkodex der
Banden wie ich später erfahre die
Ermittler nennen ihn Läufer also eine
Art Handlanger für den der Wurf der
Granate eine Mutprobe war um in der
bandenhierarchie
aufzusteigen die Unterstützer des
Angeklagten kommen später wollen aber
nicht mit uns
sprechen juni
2023 der Friedhof in Altbach der junge
Iraner springt aus dem Taxi wirft die
Handgranate auf eine Trauergemeinde sie
tragen gerade ein Mitglied der
verfeindeten Bande zu Grabe wie durch
ein Wunder prallt das tödliche Geschoss
an einem Baum ab über zehn Menschen
werden schwer
verletzt es hätten dutzende sterben
können sagt LKA Chef Andreas Stenger und
zeigt mir eine baugleiche Handgranate in
diesem schwarzen Mandel sind lauter
pleleikügelchen um diese Splitterwirkung
zu erhöhen und wenn so eine Granate
umsetzt der Sprengstoff so 1000 m pro
Sekunde dann sind es alles tödliche
Geschosse und das macht sie Hal
gefährlich also das war schon
brandgefährlich und istl absolut absolut
das ist hochgefährliche prisanteter
Kriegswaffe das ist ein Waffensystem das
mit einer prisanz umsetzt und darauf
ausgerichtet ist viele Menschen schwer
zu verletzen oder zu töten seit Sommer
2022 folgt im Großraum Stuttgart eine
Schießerei auf die nächste es dauert bis
den Beamten klar wird dass alle das
dutzende Gewaltdelikte mit mehreren
Todesopfern zusammenhängen dass zwei
Banden sich brutal bekämpfen das neue
kein Klan keine Nationalität einzieh
sondern der der
Nervenkitzel wir bezeichnen das so ein
bisschen dass ist so Kriminalität als
Lebensentwurf crimeess a lifestyle sind
überwiegend Männer jung 18 bis 28 Jahre
multiethnisch wir können feststelle dass
fast alle Migrationshintergrund haben
die meisten kommen so aus Bildung
bildungsfernen milie um zu verstehen wie
die Männer ticken analysieren die
Ermittler youtube video der Banden
Vorbilder von Rappern wie SK seine
Heimat das benachbarte Esslingen und das
sind schon Leute die zu diesen Gruppen
gehören und von denen auch supportet
werden T-Shirt Esslingen also wenn die
so Posen wenn die sich so darstellen
dann geben sie sich natürlich auch zu
erkennen wo Sie wo Sie welche
Gruppierung jeweils
sind was wichtig ist ist ja so die Texte
weil die bringen natürlich so bisschen
zum Ausdruck was was leitet ich kann
nicht vergeben und ich kann nicht
vergessen vergessen ist verraten und
Verrat nicht vergessen wir sind von der
Straße jagen wenn Stress gibt de Freund
zu Verräter Folgen Strafen nicht Gesetz
die Sage zum Teil in den Texten wir sind
kriminell do es geht uns nicht nach um
Gewinn sondern und da kommt immer Ehre
und Respekt und solche
dingeminb
we ich weiß nicht wie dust meine
Mannschaft meine Mannschaft will
blutshen was die Rapper da singen
übertragen ihre Supporter offenbar auf
Stuttgarts Straßen ich fahre in die
Innenstadt dieser Platz nahe des
Rathauses beliebter bandentreffpunkt bei
der Razia in einer der Shisha Bars
finden Polizisten eine
Maschinenpistole der Besitzer erzählt
mir dass die Banden seitdem nicht mehr
kommen will aber nicht vor der Kamera
sprechen ich spüre dass er Angst
hat
vor der Bar komme ich mit Angelo ins
Gespräch er ist Stammgast
hier ich denke heutzutage ist sehr
schwer zum Arbeiten das Lohn ist sehr
niedrig und allgemein nicht schwer
geworden und die Leute wollen leichtes
Leben haben und dann tun die sowas
erfinden und dieses Leben ist für mich
nicht ich will nachts schlafen und wie
gesagt sag ist Stuttgart viel zu viel
viel zu viele Leute viel zu viele
Ausländer wenn sie hören da wird eine
Maschinenpistole gefunden macht ihn das
auch Angst bin ich ganz ehrlich nein
weil das interessiert mich nicht ich ma
mein Ding und das war's ich kenne den
Besitzer ich ein sauberen
junge für die Stuttgarter Gruppe ist
Rapper Dadan das Idol in einem seiner
Videos halten Männer Fotos von
Verurteilten Bandenmitgliedern in die
Kamera ich grüße meine du weiß es geht
um viel Freiheit für m Freiheit für
keine Kommunikation die Z ist Freiheit
für m
fre ich grüße meine Jungs hinter Gittern
singt er ich bitte dadans Management um
Stellungnahme was sagt er zu dem Vorwurf
dass in seinen Videos Bandenmitglieder
zu sehen
sind aber ich bekomme keine
Antwort auf dem Stuttgarter
Polizeipräsidium wollen mir die Beamten
erklären wie die Banden agieren ich
würde jetzt mal zum Einstieg einfach
Video
zeige auf dem kürzlich aufgenommenen
Überwachungsvideo formiert sich eine
schwarzvermummte
bandeitt Recht schnellis auf die drumrum
sind bisschen verunsichert was soll sie
machen wie soll sich bewegen wie gesagt
das ist alles Z be Polizei
Machtdemonstration und
terrorialonstration gen insier dereren
Bande eindringen oder Rache nehmen darum
geht es auch Drogen spielen eine
Rolle auf diesem Video marschieren die
Männer auf der Kreuzung weil hier eines
ihrer gangmglieder mit dem Auto fast
getötet wurde Rache schreien sie immer
wieder die Polizei schätzt dass der
harte bandenkern mindestens 500 Männer
umfasst 60 Ermittler versuchen
herauszufinden wo es das nächste mal
knallt es ist schon nicht so dass ich
sage die haben rechts und links
Territorium sondern die überschneidet
sich teilweise haben durch kreuzungswege
das heißt es nie so richtig klar wo
erfolgt die nächste Aktion und wer macht
sie tatsächlich weil jeder hat auf
seinem Konto vermeintlich noch was offen
was zieht junge Männer in die Gangs ich
fahre nach Esslingen Revier der zweiten
Bande obwohl sich in diesem Stadtteil
der Stern eines W dreht obwohl es
eigentlich Jobs gibt ist das Viertel
sozial abgehängt hier neben diesem
Grillhaus war
202 der erste Schauplatz des
straßenkriegs wir sind vom
ZDF der Hausbesitzer zeigt mir wo die 19
Kugeln einschlugen von
wildwestzenen sprechen die
Behörden war vi Schuss num
19 in so einer Bande mit macht dann
bekommt er die Möglichkeit ein tolles
Auto zu fahren wenn es auch nicht seins
ist mit Leuten abzuhängen irgendwie
gratis Essen gratis trinken und wenn er
ehrlich arbeitet
dann ja dann dann lebt er normales Leben
dann muss er mit dem Cora
rumfahren und hat dann ein normales
Leben und in diesem Instagram Zeitalter
wo jeder pralt damit was für ein tolles
Leben er sie
führt ja da da da weckt es eben die
Begierde der
Jugendlichen im nahgelegenen Jugendhaus
bin ich mit Sozialarbeitern verabredet
was hören Sie über die Banden wir
kriegen hier sehr viel hören sagen
natürlich in Einzelgesprächen sehr viel
mit
M jetzt ins Detail das ist immer relativ
schwierig zu sagen ob das dann
tatsächlich auch alles natürlich der
Wahrheit entspricht weil da viel einfach
auch auch Ängste mit im im Raum sind
gerade wegen den jüngsten Ereignissen
irgendwo in den Landkreisen jetzt hier
die Sozialarbeiter versuchen ein
Gegenangebot zu machen Geborgenheit ein
Stück Heimat zu
bieten sonst läuft die
Schule bei mir ist alles gut soweit auf
jeden Fall also die Sogwirkung an sich
ist schon immer präsent so das ist uns
auch tatsächlich bewusst auch so diese
Anziehung irgendwo auch da ist natürlich
und ich glaube das ist schon ein der
Kernpunkte irgendwo ein Vertrauen auch
aufzubauen super wichtig und ich glaube
dann kann man auch versuchen dagegen
diesen Sog zu arbeiten wenn die
Beziehungsebene da ist aber das muss man
schon relativ früh eben machen diese
Beziehung überhaupt einzugehen die
Jugendlichen zeigen mir Ihr
Lieblingsvideo von Rapper ESC ich spüre
eine Mischung aus Angst und Faszination
keiner möchte offen sprechen Schweigen
sei Ehrensache so singen es auch die
Rapper
sie wissen dass wir nicht reden aber sie
stellen uns
Fragen mich Jahre weg
und auf der
überolpade im Zentrum das zieht sich wie
ein roter Faden durch diese Verfahren
die wir führen dass die nicht mit uns
reden dass wir vernehmungsmäßig hier
nicht weiterkommen weil die überhaupt
jedwede Form von Aussage verweigern und
Omerta kommt ja aus dem mafiabereich
dieses schweige pte das nicht geredet
wird und das ist für die natürlich auch
verbindlich weil bis lang haben wir hier
keinerlei Aussagen von denen wir haben
jetzt so viele in Haft die dann auch
schon zum Teil länger in
Untersuchungshaft sitzen aber die
vernehmungsversuche führen uns nicht
weiter weil die weil die nicht mit der
Polizei reden dazu kommt Deutschland
scheint für die Gangs ein opferstaat
Haftstrafen sind eher cool als
abschreckend Text Rapper ESC ich meine
Jungs hinter schwedischen Gardinen
siehst du die Gorillas sind so unsere
müterweinen Tränen
ausbe keine
Rehabilitation also das Thema
Gefängnisstrafen interpretiere ich eher
so dass das
durchaus für unser
Klientel ja eher erhebend ist also dass
es eher noch eine Adelung ist was also
tun Polizei und Justiz versuchen herte
zu zeigen wenn die Polizei Kenntnis von
der Straftat hat steigen wir sehr nieder
schwellig und intensiv mit auch offenen
verdeckten Maßnahmen ein
wir führen die Ermittlungen gegen unsere
high value targets konzentriert zusammen
und legen diese dann auch konzentrierter
Staatsanwaltschaft vor damit sehr rasch
und na konsequent dann Urteil erfolgen
kann aber die Sogwirkung bleibt auch auf
Einwanderer das macht natürlich Sorge
was ist mit denen die jetzt gerade
kommen wie integrieren sie sich die
nächsten Jahre hoffen nicht in diese
Gruppierungen rein das hoffen auch
Sozialarbeiter wie David Homola er nimmt
mich mit zu einem Projekt für
straffällige Jugendliche also es geht
jetzt eher darum die abzuhalten die
davon fasziniert sind oder genau es gibt
die Faszination die ist wirklich
vorhanden und es wird ja auch damit
gearbeitet junge Menschen
heranzuführen teweise schon
zjährige in die Handlung dieser krimin
Banden einzubinden und da können wir
wirksam sein und da sind wir auch
wirksam in diesem Jugendhaus leisten
junge Männer ihre Sozialstunden ab leon
hat das hinter sich er ist mit 15 in
eine kriminelle Jugendbande
abgerutscht man hatte manchmal keinen
Ort zum schlafen wenn man von zu Hause
rausgeflogen ist dann durfte man bei
Freunden schlafen hatte man mal kein
Geld man hat sich untereinander
ausgeholfen es war wenn ich so
zurückblick quasi wie eine kleine
Familie nur halt dass es keine Familie
war wo am Ende trotzdem sich jeder
hintergangen hat und hat einfach zu
nichts geführt ich habe meine Zeit
verschwendet war trotzdem eine Erfahrung
aber ich würde jedem empfehlen einen
anderen Weg zu gehen wie den Kriminellen
weit de Umfeld merkst du dass es auch
schwer ist wenn man da einmal so in
diesem Sog ist sich da wieder so
loszusagen ich musste tatsächlich zu
allen Leuten von früher Kontakt
abbrechen habe auch meine Nummer
mehrfach gewechselt weil es einfach
nicht das richtige Umfeld für mich war
und ich immer nur WE in die Scheiße
gerutscht W da muss man einfach
irgendwann mal klar den Schluss Strich
ziehen Jugendarbeit ausbauen finden sie
ist der einzige Weg investieren statt
kürzen viele unser Kids kommen einfach
aus aus sehr armen Familien ich glaube
in Deutschland un schätzt einfach was es
auch teilweise heißt dass Zugänge ja
theoretisch möglich sind zu Bildung zu
zu zu Geldern zu sonstigen Mitteln oder
auch zuur Ausbildung aber unsere
Jugendlichen kennen diese Wege oftmals
gar nicht wer hier ist bekommt
Unterstützung und braucht keine Bande
auch die Polizei fordert mehr Personal
eine bessere Software um bandenexzesse
wie in Stockholm oder mseille zu
verhindern es ist ein Wettlauf gegen die
Zeit der handgranatenwurf ist noch nicht
gesühnt auch andere Rechnungen sind
offen diese Bandenmitglieder haben laut
Polizei die angekündigte Rache vollzogen
einen jungen Mann letzte Woche mit dem
Messer attackiert und lebensgefährlich
verletzt
ка у